[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في خطوه تمهد الامكانيه
توجيهاتها لرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كشفت وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان
ترامبسا يواجه تحقيقا جنائي جديدا بشان
تعامله مع ملفات سريه بعد مغادرته البيت
الابيض وذكرت صحيفه
ان محامي ترامب تلقوا هذا الاخطار من مكتب
المدعي العام جاك سميث ما يعني ان التحقيق
يقترب من توجيه الاتهام الى الرئيس السابق
الطامح للعوده للبيت الابيض في انتخابات
العام المقبل ولم تذكر وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه متى تلقى محامو الرئيس السابق
هذا الاخطار لكن سينان كشفت ان محاميه
ترامب التقوا بمسؤولين في وزاره العدل
الاثنين الماضي لكن الشبكه ذكرت ان المدعي
العام جاك سميث المكلف بالاشراف بشكل
مستقل على التحقيق في هذه القضيه كان ضمن
مسؤلي الوزاره الذين
بمحاميه ترامب ياتي ذلك بعد حصول المدعين
العامين على تسجيل صوتي يعترف فيه
بالاحتفاظ بوثيقه سريه بعد مغادرته البيض
الابيض من جهته علاقات ترامب من خلال منصه
روسيا التي يمتلكها بانه لا احد اخبره
بانه متهم مضيفا انه لا يرتكب اي خطا
واتراك مشاهدينا متهم باستحواذه عندما
غادر البطل الابيض مطلعين 2021 على صناديق
من الوثائق الرسميه منها ما هو مصنف تحت
بند سري للغايه
مسلسل الوثائق السريه يعود من جديد شبكه
سي ان ان تنقل عن مصادر الفيدرالي حصل على
اعتراف مسرب لترامب باحتفاضه بوثيقه سريه
للبينتاكو
التسجيل المسرب يعود لعام 2021
الوثيقه تتعلق بهجوم محتمل على ايران
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من واشنطن
الخبير في سياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه دكتور
وليد فارس اهلا بك ومن واشنطن ايضا
الدكتور في القانون الدولي والخبير في
شؤون الامريكيه الدكتور نصر فياض اهلا بكم
ضيوف في الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع
دكتور ناصر دكتور ناصر يقول البعض بان هذه
الازمه قد تكون الاخطر والاكثر ثقلا على
مستقبل ترامب السياسي ما رايك
يعني لا يجب ان نستبق الامور انا اعتقد ان
هذه الادعاءات هي ادعاءات خطيره ولكن
علينا ان نذكر ان الرئيس ترامب هو ليس
موضوع
يعني اتهام الان بل هو هدف لقضيه جنائيه
وهناك فرق بين ان يكون موضوع قضيه جنائيه
او هدف قضيه جديده قد يتحول الى موضوع
قضيه جنائيه ولكن من يصنف بهدف قضيه
جنائيه هو لا يستدعي للتحقيق هو له الحق
ان يعني يعطي ادله اذا اراد او لا لذلك
يعني طبعا الاتهامات التي يتهم فيها
الرئيس ترامب اليوم هي خطيره واذا ثبتت
تعرض صاحبها
لجريمه لسجن يزيد على عشر اعوام
والشغله الثانيه ان هذا الموضوع هو ليس
جديد يعني هو من سلسله ادعاءات حصلت ضد
الرئيس ترامب من سنت بسبب سوء استعماله
للملفات السريه
فهذه ليست قضيه جديده بل هناك الان ادله
جديده اضيفت وهي ادله جديه قد تساعد
دكتور فارس سؤال مطروح في الواقع الى اي
مدى يمكن للحزب الجمهوري امتصاص مثل هكذا
ازمه او بالعكس بان هذه الازمه قد
تؤثر اكثر وقد يختلف حولها الجمهوريون
اكثر وقد تحدث انشقاقا اعمق داخل الحزب
الجمهوري
يعني العباره الاخيره انه هذا الحادث وهذا
الملف قد يحدث يعني انهيار وكارثه باعتقاد
يعني فيه البعض من المبالغه بالنظر له هذه
هذه القضيه وقضايا مماثله ليست فقط محدوده
بالزمن والمكان والوضع القانوني لهذه
القضيه انه ملف من احدى الملفات التي بدات
من ضمن المعارضه عندما اتى الى البيت
الابيض ضده نحن نذكر كم من ملف قيل انه
سوف ننهي عهده ولم ينهى وبعد ان خرج من
البيت الابيض كل هذه الملفات المتتاليه
وهذه واحده منها بالطبع على الصعود الصعيد
القانوني البحر كل ملف خطير وهذا خطير
وما يجب الان في جورجيا وقبله من ملفات
اخرى بما فيه يعني اتهامات قد سبقت هذا
الموضوع برايي انا الاهم هو الشرخ السياسي
العميق الذي هو القائم الان في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه نتيجه هذه الحرب
السياسيه هذا يجمع الجمهوريين ولا يفارقهم
بالطبع على صعيد النخبه الجمهوريه هنالك
الان مرشحين كما نعلم كثر من الذين سوف
يتبرزون مع ترامب بدانا مع ديسانتس
وانتهينا مع اخرين ولكن القاعده الجمهوريه
الارقام لا تزال موجوده 38% ككتله متراصه
مع ترامبو مع حلفاء هذا فقد يقول لنا انه
السنتين او السنه والنصف القادمه ستكون
ستكونان يعني هائجه مائجه في هذه الملفات
وقد يظهر وقد تذهب العدد يعني المؤسسات
العدليه الاتهامه يعني ان هذا ممكن لانه
كانت هنالك سابقه ولكن هل هذا سوف يؤدي
الى عزله ضمن الحزب الجمهوري الامر معقد
اكثر بتقدير نعم دكتور ناصر هل تتفق مع
دكتور وليد على ان هذه الازمه قد تمثل
ازمه تجمع الجمهوريين ولا تقسمهم وسؤال
ثاني هو الى اي مدى قادر الحزب الجمهوري
على تخطي هذه العقبات نحن بدنا نتحدث على
ازمات متتاليه اخرها هذه الازمه وربما هذه
الازمه تشمل حتى هي حلقات
نتابعها الى جانب طبعا تصريحات ترامبا
المثيره للجدل حزب الجمهوري قادر على
الصمود
يعني هل الحزب الجمهوري قادر على الصمود
او لا هذا الموضوع اخر ولكن هل هناك ازمه
ضمن الحزب الجمهوري كبيره جدا اليوم نعم
هناك ازمه كبيره واهمها ان شخصيه الرئيس
ترامب المثيره للجدل والفضائح الكثيره
التي
يعنيها الحزب الجمهوري وما زال بسبب
الرئيس ترامب وشخصيه الرئيس ترامب
والاتهامات ضد الرئيس ترامب الان نحن
قادمون على انتخاب ولكن فقط لافهم الحظر
دكتور ناصر تقول بانه هناك ازمه كبيره
تقراها داخل حزب الجمهوري بينما دكتور
فارس منذ قليل قال بانه في اخر
الاستطلاعات 38 بالمئه
يدعمون ترامب
كيف نفهم
كانوا مقربا
يقولون ان اليوم هو يحوز على اقل حتى اقل
من 34% ليس هذا الموضوع ازمه الحزب
الجمهوري الكبيره اليوم هو البلوك الكبير
الذي ما زال يتمتع به
الرئيس السابق ترامب وهو مؤثر جدا ولكن في
حال الرئيس ترامب يعني ربح التيكت
الجمهوري سيكون عند الحزب الجمهوري مشكله
كبيره جدا بالانتصار في النهايه لان هناك
فرق كبير كيف تبدا
بالانتخابات ضمن الاحزاب وعندما يصبح هناك
ممثلان كيف هو مزاج الشارع مزاج الشارع
الامريكي عامه طبعا هو ضد الرئيس ترامب
باكثريته اليوم وقياده سيؤثر كثيرا على
حدود الحزب الجمهوري لذلك انا اقول ان
الحزب الجمهوري اليوم في ازمه كثير من
هؤلاء المرشحين في ازمه الان لانه هذا
البلوك اللازم الذي ما زال موجودا عند
الرئيس ترامب والذي اعتقد انه يعني يخف
وزنه مع الوقت
يضعهم في في موقف محرج لانهم اذا يعني وق
[موسيقى]
يعني تكلموا عن كل الفضائل فضائح قد
يخسروا من هذا البلوك
اعتقد انه في المستقبل سيظهر بعض منهم
يعني يقول ان الرئيس ترامب هو عبء كبير
على الحزب الجمهوري لا يابا لهذا ويمكن
يكون هناك عدم قدره على الصمود والمواصله
دكتور فارس الى اي مدى هذا وارد هذا
البلوك هذه الكتله التي يتحدث عنها
الدكتور ناصر يقول بانه مع الوقت مع
التعليقات مع التصريحات قادره ان تخف قادر
هذا الالتفاف ان شيئا فشيئا يتلاشى في
محيط التراب الى اي مدى هذا وارد
نقرا هذا التحليل اساسا من مصادر المؤيده
لبيض المعارضه وهذا سوف نقراه ان الرئيس
ترامب يخسر ويخسر كما حصل في الانتخابات
الماضيه والتي قبلها وهنالك طبعا قراءات
الجمهوريين المتفائله انه سوف يربح يعني
الحقيقه انه الازمه الحقيقيه السياسيه هي
ليست بين الجمهوريه والديمقراطيين في هذه
المرحله هذا سوف يحسب في العام المقبل هي
بين الجمهوريين ولنكن صريحين وموضحين هي
بين
وترامب والباقي ليس له وزن وليس هنالك
حلقات واسعه لن تخطر بعد يعني من ضمن
الجمهوريين اختاروا باكثريتهم ولو كانت 38
او 37 ونصف اختار ترامب ولكن يحتاجون الى
هذه المسافه من 20 25% من الاصوات فوق
قواعد بمفرده هو غير قادر ان يربح ولكن
هنالك هؤلاء العشرين خمسه وعشرين الذي
يحتاجهم ليربح ضد بيضا وهؤلاء يتحكم
تدريجيا هذا الاتهام يعني هو الغريب
بالمنطقه الجمهوريين عندما يهاجم زعيمهم
يلتف حوله الاطراف عندما يبدا يتكلم
الرئيس ترامبو يهاجم اقسامه شخصيا انا
اسمع وارى يعطون اصواتهم الى يعني يفضلون
شخص له شخصيه كديسوندس ولكن يعرفون ان
ترامب هو بامكانها ان يجمع الاصوات
القاعده اكثر من هذا هو الدراما
الجمهوريين بتقدير في هذه المرحله جميل
تعبير دراما جمهوريين في هذه المرحله وقد
تستمر هذه الدراما كذلك في مستقبل الايام
مع اقتراب الانتخابات دكتور ناصر سؤال
مطروح هو
من النقطه التي قد تفيض الكاس ما الخط
الاحمر الذي على اثره قد يتلاشى التفاف
الجمهوريين حول ترامب ما الذي لن يسمح له
يعني انا اعتقد انه عندما يصفي المرشحون
بعضهم البعض
ويبقى اثنان قد يكون هناك مفاجات لا اعرف
انا اعتقد انها كما
اعتقد ان
الاكثريه الجمهوريه
حول
المرشح الاخر وليس الرئيس ترامب الرئيس
ترامب الحقيقه لم يضع اصدقاء
عنده في الحزب الجمهوري حتى
ليس فقط عند الديمقراطيين ان لم تكن معي
فانت عدوي عند الجمهوريين ايضا يتعاطى
الرئيس ترامب في هذه العقليه الفوقيه
واحرج على حزب الجمهوري عندما كان في
السلطه لم يكن للجمهوريين اي ملان اخر بل
دعمه
ولكن بعد ان ترك السلطه انا اعتقد انهم
يحاولون جاهدين الان عدم يعني اعطاءه
الامكانيه تمثيل الحزب الجمهوري مره اخرى
لانه يريدون العوده السلطه مع الرئيس
ترامب يعني كل
الاحصاء تقول مع الرئيس ترامب يعني هناك
امل ضعيف جدا ان ان يصبح رئيس المتحده هل
تتفق مع ذلك دكتور فارس هل من الصعب او
مهمه تولي ترامب منصب رئاسه جديد تبدو
مهمه صعبه خاصه
ممكن ان نقول فطور العلاقه بينه وبين
مجموعه من الجمهورين وكذلك حتى لا نعلم
تداعيات هذه الاتهامات ستكون هناك اتهامات
فعليه سيكون هناك حكم عليه
هل بات هذا الطموح السياسي صعب
من الخبره التي اكتسبناها جميعا يعني في
الساحه السياسيه منذ 2015 يعني نذهب الى
النقطه الثانيه التاليه لنقراطيين الى
جانب ولنضع هذا الوسط خمس لعشر ملايين
الذي يذهب بمكان او باخر وحتى في الاسابيع
الاخيره ونركز على الجمهوريه ما يسمى
النذر ترامبورز الذين هم ضد ترامب ايا كان
ولو حصل فيضان لن يكونوا مع ترامب وهم جزء
قليل ولكن المهم من الحزب الجمهوري ترامب
خسر اصوات صحيح ولكن ليس لهؤلاء يعني مش
انه كان في ناس بيحبوا ترامب وبالتالي
انتقلوا الى الوسط او الى اعدائه هؤلاء
انتقلوا الى هذه
يعني الخطر الحقيقي عليه الان هو ديسانتس
لانه ديسمبر وكانه يعني منطقي منطقي من
المفهوم اليميني والمحافظ ولكن اذا اخذ
ديسانتس الكثير من الاصوات لن يكون حفصا
لن يكون حظا لترامب لكي يربح المعركه ما
لم يفكر به احد السيناريو الذي يمكن ان
نغير كل شيء هو انه بعد معركه سته اشهر
ثمانيه اشهر قد ياتي من هو يمول ترامبو
ويمول ديسانكس ويقول لن يربط 10 فلذلك
ماذا قد يطرحون وقد ربما لن نراها الان ان
يجتمع رئيس
معقول ان يتم من جديد ان تتم العوده من
جديد انتقده في عدد المناسبات
الممولين هؤلاء يحددون المعارك لانه اذا
لم يمول الممولين
بامكانهم ان يقطعوا الخط النهائي حتى الان
كل فريق يعتقد انه مرشحهم سوف يذهب الى
الفنش ولكن اذا راوا انه ترامب يهاجم
شخصيا كثيرا ويحصل اسوار
يربح بعض الاصوات وليس احدا منهم بامكانهم
ان يصلوا الى مواجهه بايدل ولو كان بايدن
ايضا ضعيفا بحد ذاته نحن امام سيناريوهات
لن نراها في
الماضيه قد تكون هذه احدى السيناريوهاتا
او يغسل الجمهوريون البيض الابيض مره جديد
احدى من الاثنين سننتظر لنرى شكركم جزيل
الشكر من واشنطن الخبير في السياسه
الخارجي الامريكيه الدكتور وليد فارس ومن
واشنطن كذلك دكتور في القانون الدولي
والخبير في شؤون الامريكيه الدكتور ناصر
فياض شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات